so in serious 7.8 magnitude Quake hit
early this morning toppling buildings
and triggering a search for survivors in
some areas whole neighborhoods are
reported to have collapsed
turkey has declared a state of emergency
and requested International Help
hundreds of buildings have been
destroyed by the earthquake and rescue
workers are searching through piles of
collapsed concrete and Twisted Metal
let's get the latest from Ali who's
standing by for is in the region
um good morning to you Alistair what's
the latest Where You Are
good morning Kay well we've been on air
for about two hours reporting the latest
developments and in that short time the
death toll has risen threefold and I
think there is no doubt it will climb
dramatically the pictures coming out of
Southern turkey and Northwest Syria are
devastating the
Rush is now on uh to try and see if they
can recover any victims who have been
buried under the rubble but it will need
a huge information this is my report on
the latest as first light has dawned
over the region
[Music]
[Applause]
the earthquake struck a few hours before
Dawn as most people are still asleep
his first light broke across Southern
turkey the sheer scale of the damage
became evident
the death toll started to rise rapidly
and the coming hours will be an urgent
rush to find survivors under the rubble
the earthquake was powerful and shallow
only six miles beneath the surface and
it was felt around the Middle East
some of the worst reports of Devastation
are coming out of Northwest Syria where
many of the buildings are already
damaged from 12 Years of Civil War and
there are hundreds of thousands of
refugees
turkey has declared a state of emergency
and already requested international
support Aid will start arriving from
around the world but getting into
rebel-held parts of Syria will be a
challenge in itself major aftershocks
have followed the initial earthquake
including one recorded at 6.7 on the
Richter scale
the next few hours are certain to reveal
more tragedy as the rescue effort gets
underway Alistair bunkel Sky News
so as you can see from the pictures
there and they're emerging sort of every
few minutes out of Southern turkey and
Northwest Syria the devastation looks
extreme and it looks widespread The
Rescuers in turkey has a history of
earthquakes so there will be a degree of
expertise already on the ground in
Turkey they have to go gently they will
have to make sure that they don't
displace any major blocks of concrete
from the collapsed buildings and they
will do everything they can do to try
and find anyone who is trapped under the
rubble because as I said in my report it
happened just before Dawn many people
who have been asleep in their beds and
I'm afraid that probably will add to the
death toll coupled with that you've got
very bad weather particularly in
Northwest Syria it's cold rain reports
of snow as well that is not going to
help matters and then you know it's the
issue of simply trying to get Aid into
these places turkey will have its own
own the Diplomatic problems or issues
when trying to accept International Aid
although I'm sure they will do northwest
Syria is all together more difficult
because of the situation there it is
contested territory has been for more
than a decade it's War ravaged many of
the buildings already in a very very
poor condition and you've got hundreds
of thousands of refugees there is an aid
Hub in Dubai which is obviously not far
away in the region Warehouse is stuffed
full of humanitarian Aid things like
medicine food shelters and specialist
equipment that will be ready to go but
they will need to try and negotiate
access in there and they will need to do
it as a matter of urgency because in
situations like this it is no
exaggeration to say that every minute
counts and particularly the first few
hours after an earthquake like this they
try and find anybody who is still alive
buried under the rubble
yeah 360 is the latest death child that
we are hearing isn't it but we're also
hearing uh that the United States is
immediately stepping up and offering Aid
to the country that takes time to get
there though doesn't it
yeah it does take time although a lot of
these organizations and Charities who
have the expertise to deal with
earthquakes or other humanitarian
disasters are on a very short notice to
move anyway and we'll try and move in
there and often our help as quick as
possible it's not easy to reach
um that part of the world even at the
best of times
um but as I said there is that Aid Hub
in Dubai that is strategically placed in
that sort of Crossroads of the middles
Crossroads of the world really with
their airport connections and if they
can bring that into play then that will
help a great deal turkey of course is a
NATO Ally a member of NATO
um so there will be connections that
they might be able to draw on there when
dealing with some of their allies but
Northeast Syria is a whole different
ball game
um and try to get people into that
country and be able to work there in
safe 50 will not be straightforward the
white helmets the civil defense and
rescue Force that operates in Northwest
Syria is already very skilled uh
unfortunately over years having to deal
with things like air strikes and
artillery strikes buildings
um so they are on the ground but they
will need as much help as they can yeah
yeah just looking
um at Twitter just seeing president
zielinski has just been tweeting I
extend my condolences to the president
erdogan the people of turkey and the
families of those who lost their lives
in the earthquake in and wish a speedy
recovery to all the injured we stand
with the people in this difficult time
we are ready to provide the necessary
assistance to overcome the consequences
of This Disaster that's the latest that
we're hearing
um from president zielinski and I'm sure
other leaders other world leaders will
begin to Rally around very quickly um
Aleister
sure um as people start to wake up
across Europe and then into North
America the help will start coming in or
at least offers of help will start
coming in
um you can't uh fail to be shocked by
the pictures that you're seeing and I'm
sure that turkey's allies will want to
do everything they possibly can do to
offer any support and that might be
needed for that turkey as I was saying
has because of where it sits has a
history of earthquakes and um you know
it's not a good thing it was to compare
one to the other but the last worst uh
the last earthquake they had major
earthquake they had was in 1999 when 17
000 people lost their lives and the
death toll in this is nowhere near that
yet but it is climbing rapidly and I'm
sure it will raise questions within
turkey again uh in the aftermath of this
building standards housing standards and
whether or not a lot of the
infrastructure particularly in southern
turkey which is a slightly poorer area
of the country whether or not they are
built sufficient standard to withstand
uh earthquakes the history and the
vulnerability turkey has to suffering
natural disasters like this